hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time for episode four in our series
of ps4 games you can download for free
right now if nothing on this list takes
your fancy then be sure to check out the
other 30 games we've covered in previous
videos if you'd like other people to
play alongside then use the comment
section below to write your PSN names in
and the game you want to play with
others then squad up and get playing all
right let's do this let's start with the
latest game to hit the PlayStation Store
happy dungeon this is a role-playing
game where you and three other friends
tear your way through multiple dungeons
as you can already tell by the art style
happy dungeon is not trying to replicate
a photorealistic world but instead opts
for a warmer more lighthearted way to
play an RPG character creation in happy
dungeon is almost limitless with highly
customizable heroes with different
skills there is some absolutely weird
and wonderful stuff in here so dress
like a knight if you want or a teddy
bear with a moustache if that floats
your boat the world is yours for the
taking in terms of the storyline it's an
age-old tale of a kidnapped princess you
and your fellow Knights must rescue the
three main class types our warrior hits
erect beaches in close up combat the
mage or magic abilities and the cleric
who is a mixture of the other two but
with a focus on healing to happy dungeon
is fresh out of beta status and supports
both online and split-screen couch co-op
so give it a try if you need a group
bang your psn in the comments and find
like-minded gamers next up we take the
action to another level with cut the
fish not Call of Duty yeah a fishing
game really okay I know this is a niche
audience but still worth a mention as
there are hundreds of thousands of
fishing fans who deserve a videogame
outlet for their passion this is fishing
planet this is a simulation with
impressively realistic waves currents
and a dynamic weather system fish
behavior is probably the most realistic
in videogame history well except for
Ocarina of Time of course if that was
perfection every detail is covered in my
new detail with multiple
types and real-world fishing methods
which could actually make you a better
angler in real life so maybe see this
one as a training outlet too there are
more than 70 species of fish 12
waterways and multiple locations even
the seasons change play this one alone
or online with up to 64 players I really
wish I liked fishing as this appears to
be the catch of the day boom sorry next
on the list is dreadnought which is in
open beta status at present
in this one you are tasked with
dominating the skies using a big hulking
capital warship you are the captain in
this class based war fest each vessel
has its own strengths and weaknesses
meaning even the smallest opposition can
strategize and take down the most
powerful warships there's currently 61
starships in the game with a tier system
used to represent advanced ships with
legendary weapons the grind is real in
dreadnought meaning the more time you
put in the more rewards you uncover have
you played this one already or are you
going to try it out is the grind real
please let us know
dreadnought doesn't require ps+ at
present but those with PS plus are
rewarded with the dreadnought + pac
which awards you with the Ravenswood
emblem and decal and the Ravenswood
coating for your ship not much but still
a nice gesture let's try something
completely different adventure pop did
you ever play puzzle bobble it was a
simple but effective arcade game which
made it to home consoles in the 1990s
well adventure pop is exactly the same
well not exactly the same you know
copyright changes here and there of
course there's not much to say about
this one going head-to-head with AI or a
friend your job is to burst bubbles
using a cannon there is a campaign here
but these types of games are not really
here for narrative it's simply the joy
of wrecking a friend and never letting
them forget even 20 years later next on
the list is ox must die Unchained this
wooden may look all pretty and friendly
but in this outing you'll be murder
izing millions of args this is
ultimately an action based tower defense
game in which you set up barricades and
traps to stop the oncoming orc invasion
it's that slow but in no time you'll be
running around like a headless chicken
setting up your defenses and claiming
headshot after headshot oh that reminds
me another game coming free next year is
fortnight which is almost identical to
the action elements in arms must die so
if you plan to download that one thing
this first to get your defensive skills
flushed out ox must die Unchained has
many game modes including survival which
is the typical wave based scenario
you're already imagining but there's
also siege which is a multiplayer battle
arena style fight there's also of
sabotage mode with two teams fending off
ox which in turn allows tougher ox to be
summoned to the opposition side I hope
that made sense Orcs Must Die Unchained
supports up to three players online are
you going to give this one a try if you
are
comment below and find a team let's
break away from orc destroying and find
a game without anyone's head been
detached
this is stern pinball arcade the reason
I'm bringing this one up is because I
recently started playing Sonic Spinball
on the genesis on Megadrive
and I couldn't help but love it again
well stern pinball arcade is a throwback
to the time when pinball tables were all
the rage you already know that pinball
is all about high scores but the
cabinet's created in this game are
simply amazing recreating classic tables
are referencing movies there's even one
for Last Action Hero
you know that terrible Arnold
Schwarzenegger film pain you want to be
a farmer here's a couple of acres I know
this one isn't for everyone but a break
from your typical games or a blast from
the past
stern pinball arcade is worth a try next
is a game I missed recently games of
glory this is a free-to-play top-down
team shooter or arena shooter if you
prefer your first step is to choose from
five class types and load outs of over
50 weapon types next one player is
selected as the superstar of the team
and that person must survive until the
end of the game this will force you and
all the other players to change their
play style to protect that superstar
next well all hell breaks loose
there is more to it than that but I
think that gives you the basics games of
glory supports four on four and three
versus three game modes but the server
supports ten players so maybe more
content is on the way soon the weapon
types are the main focus balancing
long-range snipers against rocket
launchers and even flamethrowers this
one requires communication so use the
comments below to find people as always
your opinion or review would really help
so let us know what you think of it once
you've tried it until next time folks
let's have a look at World of Tanks I
know what you're thinking it's been
around since 2010 it's been on ps4 for
over a year
well the constant upgrades and changes
made this game deserve a spot on the
lasing 60 the premise is simple grab a
tank we team up with allies and blow the
[ __ ] out of the opposition recently
though the user base has dropped off and
to get people interested again on the
ps4 you can download the updated bundle
pack through the PlayStation Store
rewarding you with a German Panzer s 35
tank a 100% trained crew and additional
garage slot repairs and first-aid kits a
100 thousand pieces of silver currency
and a whole lot more for many people to
start a game which has been out for many
years is quite daunting but if you're
new to World of Tanks this extra pack
should help you step up and not be
cannon fodder well once you've mastered
it of course if you know me you know I'm
hyped for monster hunter world this has
led me to find free to play games
in a similar vein that's where touka den
- comes in this is the free alliance
version which also requires PS Plus just
to clear things up a little if a friend
has the full game you can play alongside
them with the Alliance version in to get
in - you'll be tracking down beasts and
hunting them in a group of Slayers or
alone if you prefer with access to
eleven weapon types there is a ton to
master but there's also a weapon to suit
every play style the story
unintentionally represents people from
outside of Japan as demons which is
strange if they want to sell copies over
here this version of - curtain - doesn't
give you access to all elements of the
full game as it's really here to give
you a flavor of the gameplay mainly the
stamina levels will become an issue as
they are integral to exploration this
will take 8 real-time hours to replenish
so that's a pretty big stumbling block
to get over tempted let us know your
thoughts
[Music]
and finally something small to finish
off and it's something for the psvr
users of the world spider-man
homecomings er this is nothing near a
full game it's more like a tech demo
advertising the latest spider-man movie
this one puts you in the web-slinger's
of Peter Parker as he receives his first
full-fledged Spidey suit it's
essentially a shooting gallery but
having a scrap with vulture at the top
of a crane he's a pretty great
experience it'll only take ten minutes
to complete but it's worth it and even
better if you could convince your mother
to play it but without the cosplay of
course that could get awkward so there
you go there's ten more video games you
can play for free on ps4 you can
download them right now please find
people to play with in the comments and
let me know what you are going to
download I'm playing to Gordon and Orcs
Must Die Unchained but what about you
I'm Adam from PlayStation granade it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]